more than three generations of
moviegoers this is the face the face of
the most popular woman in the world this
is the face of Mary Pickford she had
made more than 160 films before Rebecca
of Sunnybrook farm a classic that
established her forever as America's
Sweetheart her range is an artist is
legendary perhaps no other actress
anywhere has ever run the gamut of
theater from Maggie bad slapstick a poor
little pepino to romantic high comedy of
Shakespeare's shrew a forlorn waif in
rags and both Duchess and tomboy and
little Lord Fauntleroy
tragic Madame Butterfly and the slave he
insults and the poor little rich girl
she created unique and personal film
literature
you
in 1927 for United Artists the company
she had organized with Douglas Fairbanks
Charlie Chaplin and DW Griffith she made
her last silent film my best girl with
Charles bloody Rogers
in 1929 Mary Pickford was singled out by
the Academy for her outstanding
performance in Coquette the second act
was so honored with an Academy Award
this is miss Pickford's home today
and we are here to present her with a
special award voted by the Board of
Governors to honor one of the Academy's
founders Douglas Fairbanks on this
estate in 1919 gave it to his bride as a
wedding gift
the press of the day call it picture a
name that identifies it to this day
and now for the first time cameras are
bringing you up the driveway has it been
traveled for over 50 years by kings and
commoners movie stars in Prime
Minister's sports and scientists
musicians artists movie fans holiday you
know Will Rogers once said that his
biggest job as mayor of Beverly Hills
was to direct tourists to Mary
Pickford's house among those visitors
were the king queen of Siam they rule
Duke Adventures father Crown Prince of
Japan Marconi Einstein Amelia Earhart
Charlie Chaplin and Oscar himself and
here they were entertained in the
Regency dining room the gold candelabra
were the gifts of another gift a lady
who was a ballet whoa was devouring a
Miss Pickford is to fill this immortal
problem this is a classical portrait of
Miss pictured by the renowned Spanish
artist Deena
wings first ever to win an Oscar start
her husband of 39 years Buddy Rogers
Mary I presented to you with great pride
and with a love and admiration of the
whole Academy that's wonderful you made
me very very happy
I'm just thank you well it's nice to see
another isn't it it certainly is he
hasn't changed very much in all this
time as he well I hope not
no he hasn't he hasn't there been a lot
of being made and a lot of marvelous
actors and actresses have won him and it
it's only proper but finally he's come
back to you again well it's very nice to
be able to thank them all and especially
you thank you and you for all you've
contributed to this great industry of
ours
I should say always
you